no they couldn't carry a tune
to save their lives actors like you
don't come by often Joaquin Phoenix you
love playing challenging roles and your
fans love watching you bring them to
life on the big screen you're a
dedicated actor who will go to extreme
lengths to walk a mile in your character
shoes when you take on a new role you go
all-in no matter how mentally or
physically demanding it turns out to be
Joaquin Phoenix has been known to do
extreme things for a role from wiring
his jaw shut to acting like a caged
animal on set to becoming a real-life
firefighter there's just no way of
knowing what he'll get up to next keep
watching to find out how Joaquin tricked
the world into thinking he'd lost his
mind all while preparing for a secret
role thinking about it isn't uncommon
for actors to gain or lose weight when
portraying a character of a different
build Anne Hathaway lost in arresting 25
pounds when she played Fantine in limos
Arab and Matthew McConaughey took things
even further when He shed thirty-eight
pounds to star in Dallas buyers club but
most recently Joaquin Phoenix took
things to the next level when he lost 52
pounds to play Arthur Fleck in the Joker
according to the actor shedding the
weight was so challenging simple tasks
like climbing the stairs became a burden
Joaquin talked about his drastic weight
loss while on Jimmy Kimmel Live
admitting that while the transformation
had been difficult it had also been very
empowering to hit his goal weight
Phoenix refrained from watching TV as
food commercials proved to be his
biggest triggers during his segments
with the New York Times the actor
revealed that at first he didn't want to
lose weight for the role
however director Todd Phillips was
adamant about what he thought that Joker
should look like and his vision included
Arthur being so thin his rib cage
protruded in an unhealthy way all I have
are negative thoughts
back in 2005 joaquin phoenix landed the
role of a lifetime he portrayed the
legendary Johnny Cash and walked the
line opposite Reese Witherspoon's June
Carter Joaquin embodied Johnny in both
mind and spirit going as far as to learn
to sing and play the guitar like Johnny
himself he faced some challenges along
the way
his voice was reportedly too high
causing the band to have to play songs
in a higher key then miraculously
Joaquin managed to perfect Johnny's
voice right before filming started
resulting in the band having to relearn
the soundtrack and its original key but
that wasn't the only issue the crew
faced while filming walked the line as
Joaquin had some absurd requests in the
name of accuracy while filming the
Folsom Prison sequence he insisted that
the extras be treated like real inmates
the cast wasn't allowed to eat drink or
go to the toilet this sacrifice helped
set the mood Joaquin was aiming to
achieve Joaquin Phoenix isn't someone
who shies away from method acting in
fact it's sort of his thing he committed
to perfecting his craft no matter how
long it takes while filming I'm still
here
Joaquin decided to inhabit his character
for a whopping 18 months he tricked the
world into thinking he was done with
acting and choosing to pursue a rapping
career instead Casey Affleck documented
his every move and Joaquin began to take
on a disheveled look in public growing
more and more uncapped with each passing
day he made outrageous claims and print
interviews and mumbled his way through
every TV appearance the most notable one
taking place during an interview on The
Late Show with David Letterman
when Joaquin appeared confused
irrational and unable to form a sentence
only once the film came out did Joaquin
admit to pranking the world for over a
year
if that isn't dedication we don't know
what is
back in 2004 when Joaquin was 30 years
old he was cast as Jack Morrison in the
heart-wrenching movie ladder 49
Phoenix's performance was nothing short
of amazing and firefighters everywhere
were surprised by his knowledge of the
profession it was almost as if he was a
legitimate firefighter himself and as it
turns out he was too bond with his
character who was seen as a rookie
Joaquin enrolled in the Baltimore Fire
Academy and later graduated shortly
after he joined the crew 10 and helped
them put out real fires ladder 49
director Jay Russell was impressed by
how far wall Keane went to become his
character after becoming a firefighter
and understanding what they went through
on a daily basis Joaquin was able to
bring his role home making for an
incredible performance
Joaquin bonded with the brave men he
worked with and would go on to get the
unit's mascot busy be tattooed on whom
riding alongside firefighters and
watching them in action wasn't enough
for the actor who chose to go all the
way instead
in 2018 Joaquin Phoenix would take on
yet another challenging role but this
time he would put his body at risk in a
whole new way
Joaquin was cast as Jesus and Mary
Magdalene the film was shot in Sicily
which is known for its delicious pasta
and wine unfortunately for Joaquin he
wouldn't get to indulge during his time
off the set as he was on a strict 300
calorie a day diet Joaquin was
determined to look like Jesus but to do
this he had to shed tons of weight he
also grew out his hair and beard to
better help him understand his character
state of mind on top of meeting the bare
minimum Joaquin used his starvation as
fuel and it helped him get closer to
Jesus the actor read all four Gospels -
but this only succeeded in confusing him
as some of the information was said to
be contradictory Joaquin told Village
Voice that instead of focusing on the
mystical side of Jesus he was trying to
find his humane side and your spirit is
precious to God
joaquin knows that looking the part has
a lot to do with acting the part which
is why he pushes his body to new heights
each time he takes on a new role while
the actor is no stranger to losing
dozens of pounds for a role he's also
accustomed to gaining a lot of weight
over a small period of time in 2000
Walken played the villainous historical
figure communists in the movie Gladiator
but getting into character wasn't an
easy thing for the acclaimed actor to do
in fact he was so nervous when he
arrived on set he had to be fed drinks
and walked through his scenes but that
all changed when Joaquin finally
connected with Commodus in that moment
he realized that he needed to gain
weight cut his hair and carry a sword to
fully develop this character and that's
exactly what he did
despite his on-screen counterparts
despicable nature Joaquin was able to
locate his inner child and connect with
that little humanity he had inside him
his performance and gladiator would go
on to garner Oscar and Golden Globe
nominations keep watching to find out
which movie Joaquin committed to so
furiously he hurt himself numerous times
while filming you take life when you
have to then in 2017 Joaquin Phoenix was
cast as Joe and you were never really
here Joe who was a traumatized military
vet had a very specific body type one
that Phoenix couldn't master by putting
on weight alone the actor wanted his
body to be both fit and flabby there
I'll get her so he put on some weight
while working out at the same time but
Joaquin's weight gain was far from being
the movie's biggest surprise in the end
it was revealed that Phoenix shot the
movie in just 29 days seeing as he had a
very busy schedule director Lynn Ramsay
had to work fast to keep up with Joaquin
who on most days wasn't even given the
script Flynn gave Joaquin complete
freedom choosing to base her movie
around his performances the film was
described as a creative storm but
thankfully Joaquin's unpredictable
nature paid off
one year later in 2018 joaquin portrayed
a disabled cartoonist named john
callahan in don't worry he won't get far
on foot this challenging role required a
lot from him
but that wasn't a problem for the
committed actor myself looking for
better bays joaquin studied the memoir
the movie was based on going as far as
practicing cartooning on top of watching
real-life footage of callahan and
adopting his humor and body language
joaquin visited the same rehabilitation
center callahan had been placed in after
his accident he spent months in Rancho
Los Amigos where he talked to patients
and caregivers about wood beam
quadriplegic really meant it was here
that he studied how to restrict his
movements it all paid off in the end as
joaquin was able to finally immerse
himself into his role eternal virtue is
the one of Joaquin Phoenix's most
demanding roles was the one of Freddie
quell in the master the movie which came
out in 2012 followed a world war two
veteran as he fell under the spell of a
menacing cult leader to properly convey
the vast emotions of his character
Joaquin remained in character throughout
the entire filming process so much so
that he harmed himself by accident on
multiple occasions Freddie quell was
someone who had a very distinctive sneer
and Joaquin wanted to take on his look
so the actor visited his dentist and
asked to have his jaw wired shut
believing this would be the best way to
maintain a clenched jaw
throughout the production director Paul
Thomas Anderson was shocked to see how
far the actor would go to emote on the
screen Joaquin would become so invested
in his character that he would
accidentally destroy a toilet on set
during a very emotional scene as it
turns out Joaquin had studied the way
wild animals reacts when in captivity he
took note of how hard they fought to
escape which often resulted in them
hurting themselves in the process the
wild and unpredictable nature of these
animals sir
as fuel for the actor on several
occasions Joaquin acted like a caged
animal resulting in real-life injuries
Anderson who had heard of walkins method
acting skills never once suspected that
he would bring so much creativity to his
character he was both stunned and
impressed by Joaquin skillset and that's
a wrap before you go tell us what your
favorite Joaquin Phoenix movie is in the
comments below
secrets thanks for watching the things
don't forget to Like and subscribe for
more we'll see you next time